hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The Last
of Us okay we're still running away from
the soldiers in the city and trying to
get out to the forest up the outside
okay we got a big pipe here through here
yes we can definitely make it through
here thank you for your positivity Joel
come on Ellie and Tess this isn't a good
situation because in any sort of game
especially ones with zombies in it
sewers are not a good idea
sewers are never a good idea good job
finally it's about time those soldiers
gave up the search I mean we're really
not worth it they don't even know that
we killed them how do they know how do
they know Syria they must change out for
higher resolution models during the
cutscenes because he's look really good
alright they're gone
what was the plan let's say that we
deliver you moved to the fireflies what
then
Marlon's she said that they have their
own little quarantine zone with doctors
they're still trying to find a cure yeah
we've heard that before Nantes and then
whatever happened to me is the key to
finding a vaccine oh Jesus that's what
she said oh I'm sure she did
hey [ __ ] you man I didn't ask for this
me neither
Tess what the hell are we doing here
what if it's true I can't
what if Joel and we've come this far
let's just finish it do I need to remind
you what is out there I get it
you get what then I'm scared I'm a
little baby I'm a baby man walking
around in a grown-up body this way if we
cut through downtown we can hit the
Capitol building by Sunrise Capitol
building I thought we were trying to get
outside Oh strange okay anyway we're
still pushing forward I just don't know
where I'm kind of at a loss for the
direction that we're going but I'll keep
moving forward it's the last thing I do
cuz I am a professional badass in these
games and I will stop at nothing to make
sure that Ellie gets there safely man I
love the seniors it's actually like just
everything reminds me of different games
I always like to make comparisons
between different games because then
thematically a lot of them are similar
this one suddenly reminded me of Crysis
test you hear that yeah pretty far away
though I didn't hear anything
what'd you hear I'm gonna turn up my
volume for now come on we're never safe
Ellie always must be vigilant yeah but
this reminds me of crisis when I was
playing it before see I love games I
really do games are awesome okay I don't
want to fall off if I fall off here I
will die thanks Ellie are you gonna push
me off excuse me
need a little room here there's the
Capitol building okay yeah you need to
get around this mess whatever you say
Ellie you want to count town you know
you want to give me some room here I'm
kind of feeling close to Rupp I can't I
can't give me Ellie Ellie really
seriously Ellie Ellie Ellie why are you
doing this to me Ellie what's going on
with it la Li mo mo thank you thank you
very much Ellie thank you thank you very
much
Ellie she's trying to kill me this girl
this is probably why I have such a bad
feeling about all this
because I know things are gonna go wrong
you gotta go through the old stone
building whatever this is gonna be good
I'm sure it's full of happiness and
rainbows just like everything else in
this game this does have kind of a
horror feel to it like right now anyway
okay so the open old doors will always
have a little circle on them so that I
can actually figure out what may have
stuff in it anything in there nope okay
no scavenger balls
okay wait no that's where I came from I
don't need to drop out there come on
follow along little children oh that's
not good part yeah body's pretty fresh
oh boy yeah might be yeah stick around
seriously this does have quite the
horror feel to it I wonder if there are
some sincerely scary parts in this game
I would love that
because I mean any zombie apocalypse
game preys on fear
hello let's thank you very much what is
that sound cuz I heard it that time what
is that
oh god Damon clicker ill Oh what's wrong
with his face I don't want to know
confectional duty yeah you are they sort
of they see using sound like all Rudy
like bats here we're clicking you got a
hide that's up to okay well that's why
they call them clickers makes total
sense I guess
Oh bill it feels like it's about to fall
apart
yeah supplements ooh I still have no
idea of the types of items that are
available it's game cuz I've heard I've
heard that there's some sort of crafting
system available but this is just really
cool can see a game half-life the
half-life 2 creators - uh talked about
this before a game should um prep play
into all of a person's emotions while
you it should make you feel a ride whoa
what the hell
quick come of it now don't slap me fish
yeah Oh mushrooms going out of your
whole face you're right laughing did I
get bit cuz my health went down by a lot
okay I'll search for supplies you
weren't even the one pinned to the
ground what you weren't either test I
was the one it was me the whole time you
guys were just taking all the glory
fruit me scared me test you may want to
look in this cabinet where there's a
bottle of water oh cool ooh I really
hope that when I get out to the willness
I will have to scavenge for food because
that is one of the things in these
survival games that is often missing I
really think you have to open the door
it's yourself up
cool so I use my ship as a sort of
picklock did it consume the ship but
there's goodies in here awesome
grab it all Joel get it all supplements
god I really hope that I need to get
rations for surviving oh man that would
be so cool
I can't wait I can't wait I'm so excited
about this game
like I've been geeking out about this
game for a while no I'll take the brick
thank you very much I've been geeking
out about this game for a long time so
I'm really really excited to get out
there oh god
ha ha ha I love this game so much so I
just need to vent my nerdness musket
every once in a while boy
yep you said it buddy look this party's
away food is there a health kit up there
because I kind of need one I can't I
could jump that all right kid you're up
ah the kid why not me we go what the
hell I'm not important enough jeez what
it's fine I'll just get out here okay
come on let's go huh sorry I'm so fat
hmm been packing on the pounds I could
have sworn something bad was gonna
happen the first [ __ ] Coco oh you hear
we huh
oh oh oh you're disgusting
Oh No thank you go away please if there
isn't already survival horror stuff in
this this would make a great horror game
excuse me I have oh hold extra craft
wait I can make out a ragged alcohol
table I can cool sweet I need one really
badly finally full help yeah oh do not
come here whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa well
we getting a little close there you go
over there did you see anything didn't
see a thing
okay let's go let's go let's go people
come on Ellie I guess there's no
differences between bricks and bottles I
would assume that if you hit something
with a brick
it would hurt a lot more wouldn't it go
over there please thank you very much
hello what is this over the skin oh
there was a bar right there I could have
been damn it
never mind let's go let's go let's go
Ellie hurry up we don't got long OOP all
right moving right along crisis
thoroughly averted Ellie you okay oh
here's a medkit guy pants whatever fine
Ellie did you really did you really or
are you exaggerating are you
exaggerating just a little bit maybe
fine whatever give me a second all right
this is gonna make a lot of noise
oh wait now I'm pulling it up there you
go ladies all right
okie dokie mr. walz blocked should we go
back up nope
I sincerely wish that they at some point
separate us because this would be crazy
awesome just don't look down
he's serious yes Ellie stop being a
little baby you Jewish baby water bottle
baby water teddy bear oh yeah I would
not make a good fire I've constantly
taught my my daughter son even if
especially my son was being a baby I'd
be like Oh little baby who want your
bottle like they're three years old I'm
like oh who's crying like we or no I
tell you the story about him one of my
cousins stole my Easter Cundy candy I
say I said that right my cousin who's
like two or not my cousin my nephew my
nephew stole my Easter candy and so I
chased after him I going that was my
candy and he searched crying like a
little baby where where and then I take
the candy from him I you didn't you good
I said that in a mail video don't know
if everyone heard it though okay good I
need one of these
now I'm gonna beat the crap out of a
clicker what is that over there
something that I need gun whoa really
does this replace my gun right now cool
is probably a bit more powerful usually
revolvers are okay you can carry more
guns than you have holsters extra guns
are stored in your inventory and can be
swapped with an equipped gun hold X to
bring out your inventory okay so I got
it so if I go over to the right and hold
X I can swap it for the revolver okay
cool cool beans awesome awesome awesome
oh okay I get it can I can I move now
good eye good eye good eye
hey Joel Joel Joel buddy buddy oh and it
wants me to oh it wants me to swap for
the revolver okay that's what I want I
got it really was that really necessary
stay with the group damn forced
tutorials what the hell
ooh what the hell you're sending me it
alone why why do I need to do this why
is this necessary
oops whoa hi
where'd you come from you wanna f off
forever
okay here time to be loud boom oh crap
how the dumber awesome some really dumb
I'm stupid oh crap
ow oh ah I'm just gonna run straight
growth this is a bad idea from the
beginning oh this is dumb this was so
dumb why did I use my gun did I use my
gun crap crap crap crap shoot him hit
him hit him scrap up BAM ah don't bite
me don't bite me you son of a [ __ ]
don't even get close
oh what the Oh where'd you come from I'm
sorry
number no one saw anything
yeah don't say a word it was the first
time I died cuz I did a stupid dumb
thing yeah so you all just relax and
cool your jets while I be very cautious
now oh I didn't even use my I didn't
even use my super sense of hearing I'm
so dumb okay so that's the only one
there I see I need to strangle this one
you don't hear a thing everybody okay
I'm good so just be very careful
strangle and be very quiet hmm
it's weird I really wonder what the
infection does to these people I would
love I love to read science like the
pseudoscience that is available in some
of these games hello there friend
how you doing it sounds like you need a
distraction how about a giant bottle
going way the hell over there Oh wha
why would why did I come down here again
I'm guessing I need to get over there to
be able to move that device that I was
trying to move before why it didn't seem
to work out in my favor there are a lot
of these things how in the world am I
gonna get it oh oh oh oh oh okay am i
waking on my way scheisse oh no no no no
no no no no no no okay
so apparently getting outnumbered like
this is a bad idea
so I'm going to get this one since I
find a wall clicker oh okay don't turn
around buddy
I'm gonna get this clicker you just stay
way over there I'm gonna get the clicker
hi friend that's going hey Joel looking
good buddy you've been working out look
like
okay turn around maybe okay almost done
stop ah time is now time is now what now
what now all the time was my that was my
time to shine what the hell that's so
dumb that was dumb now it's just plain
and simple those stupidness to the
extreme I'm so angry that that happened
I don't know hey maybe I'm just an idiot
okay fine got that one the others are
gonna cycle around there the clickers
gonna move I need to get that brick
where am I going okay what we're gonna
do is I'm gonna lead them into this
hallway here I'm gonna try to make some
noise so that they all come over here
whoa no come on hit him brew yes
everyone go for the sound please thank
you very much whoa okay I refined so far
that clicker is being a bastard I may
have to just shoot this guy I'm taking a
bit too long anyway
okay got him you're the guy there you
got him one drop you with the pipe ya
got ya
whoa where'd you come from got surprised
yeah not too big a [ __ ] right king of
this jungle come on down I'm just fine I
don't think I took a point of damage on
that I should have done that from the
beginning you can always add learned
prioritize the clickers fish clock get
out of here it was nothing I am too
badass to be distracted by anybody are
you impressed
madam you impress I need to find more
pipes these pipes do not last nearly
long enough okay so I need to go up here
and then move the thing out of the way
of the doorway herp a derp derp got it
moving moving maybe come on
Jemma I can see how that would have not
been possible with the zombies behind
there
okay let go vigil Joe let go of it Joel
Tesco okay I'm holding hold on hurry up
any minute now thank you thank you for
not forgetting about me huh you're the
best love you love all of you see all
right you got another bottle of water
which is good more supplies over here
some scissors tape I'm full on health
kits or was that just a candy bar
probably just a candy bar which meant
that I could have rejuvenated the Melfi
if I took some damage which I did not
crap we jumping down down we go alright
madam do it
Oh we're not jumping down there's a way
down here okay jumping down would have
been just do here watch your back what
happen to your hand there Joel don't
think I didn't see that some of the some
of the bugs in this game you're just a
little wonky but that's okay I can
forgive it okay any scavenger bowl
scavenger bulls anything that can help
me
no nothing alright don't need him I'm
too awesome no I was thinking yeah after
we get back
uh-huh you can take it easy for a little
while yeah
you all hey you're the one always going
on about laying low and you always brush
me off uh-huh well well we're going that
way so I just wanted to take a bath see
it all right let's see dead body
lovely always good to see that hep hep
all right
still don't know what we're looking for
it just like I'm traveling through a
maze with no direction that can barely
being guided along like if I was really
in this place I wouldn't have no idea
where I was supposed to go cuz the whole
objective is to get to the capital
building for some reason I have no idea
why more supplies I mean obviously the
dropper off the Y there that's what I
don't know can I get those scissors is
that full - okay full-on scissors it's
kind of wait I'm full-on scissors Oh
more bolts nuts and bolts goody goody
gumdrops don't know what those are for
yet but I will find out soon enough
I am guessing and what do we have over
here more supplements goody goody
gumdrops
some dead guy's sleeve Firefly yep these
guys aren't doing well in or out of the
city
mmm Molotov suite all right good for me
a burning enemy can even set fire to
others good so there's some meters of
the drop-off okay leave that there for
now I need me another bottle of brick
guys okay over here yeah it's blocked
off seems like that's not gonna be a
good way to go another note Firefly map
a map that seems like it'd be important
yeah see Capitol gold dome meet up with
second Firefly team at Capitol building
girl 5 foot 3 14 year olds red hair okay
well that seems obvious see they're not
our guys uh-huh they seem like our guys
okay through here down and under I got a
bad feeling about this
oh oh yeah so what are we gonna do about
that okay Joey you take point I'll watch
the view Ellie
no matter what you stay right on his
heels sure you stay sharp I got it I got
it unlike last time I am totally in
control here
clicker stealth clickers can still hear
you when you're crouched push L lightly
to move more quietly with your heard
stop and wait until it's safe to move
okay so I can have my light on right cuz
they're blind at least I think that okay
so I just need to be very whew
don't move don't move it's coming right
for me what do i what do I do about that
okay okay so I just need to be very very
quiet Ellie on my heels not in my face
okay okay
honing in wherever got just be very
everybody shut up be very careful we
don't want to disturb anyone here we
want to be very stealthy okay okay just
be very controlled in your movements
don't make a move I have been signed out
of the PlayStation Network again don't
make oh don't move tell joy their
clickers all over the place where am I
supposed to go I don't know where I'm
supposed to go I think maybe there was a
door over this way this is nerve-racking
they're all right I'll start panicking
shut up you're creepy
wait those aren't those aren't clickers
okay I need to pick up a bottle here
okay can I go through there I thought I
saw clicker move into there oh oh oh oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no it's gonna
give me Oh No it's gonna give me oh oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh no oh no oh
no okay I got this I got this I got this
I got this it's one in the way we can
get by him by doing this
go for it man go go I thought I thought
I saw an enemy over god damn it where am
I supposed to go anyway oh I see it
right okay I'll just do this go man go
yeah Oh some wasn't that sure we'll stop
oh man check that out for about five
minutes straight okay here we go this is
a dead end I thought all the others like
hotel is this hotel is this bull visible
visible what's going on here this bull
get out why I they're gonna come eh go
away over there thank you where am I
supposed to go oh I see I see I see okay
this is gonna make a lot of noise isn't
it be quiet please thank you
here's fine yeah that wasn't noisy go up
go up go up go up go go go ladies first
go Ellie Ellie no screw you Ellie I'm
going next
scrub god oh my god Bobby oh sorry I
don't handle stress soul situation very
well sorry Ellie sorry I like pushed you
out of the way a ladder I apologize
sincerely for that I'm not sorry at all
oh [ __ ] we actually made it yeah how
about that everyone okay no my pride is
broken
let's move yeah let's move here's your
crawling stuff its console when we were
hired and it is gonna run out someday
it's odd how the main characters of
video games are always so lucky to l
Madeline Tess uh
capital buildings in this direction how
do you know how do you know how do you
know Tess I don't see a capital building
how do you know
get up over this truck we don't that's
the answer let's see what we can find
huh how about idea how the bad idea I'll
get him oof
Bibble yeah bass be crap crap crap why
am i punching them why am i punching all
of the zom zoms take that cuz I'm just a
normal fisticuffs master even test
speeding up the zom zoms that's what I
called him
the zom zoms my little thing that was
dumb no really I walked right into that
I didn't think they would be in there
atom soldiers must have just turned
which means there's more in the area we
gotta go huh how the hell does this
keypad wait what am I doing here I'm
losing this outside so we can get up
over the truck I'm guessing like like
that why couldn't we have just climbed
up on the hood of the never mind never
mind I don't care okay up me first
the handsome ones go first all right
there Ellie do you need some help you
little wimpy baby
whew new sumo would you do baby help
climbing up the truck oh oh
you okay there don't strain it up came
in sorry I'm an [ __ ] okay this time
I'm actually gonna be careful and not
run dead smack into some zom zoms
all right we're okay right we're okay
okay we're okay I am hope what do you
think I'm doing something gonna appear I
always get a bad feeling when I do these
things what I don't know anything okay
double time yeah I heard some they're
coming I know
oh crap come on come on
you got some on your shoe Oh Oh grody
let's see all right then like like I
said I don't know how far along I get
out of this so I need to like judge it
so I don't like cut something important
off in the middle of something so let me
think here yeah I think I'm gonna cut it
here for now wait hang on let me listen
to this well how were you bitten I mean
you must have been somewhere you
shouldn't find an infected exam
yeah that's sneaked out I was in this
[ __ ] hmm
you know sweetie yes I was in the mall
when I ran into infected yeah that was
pretty dumb of you women how the hell
did you get mayor
I had my ways mm-hmm that was that I see
yeah
I must have sucked okay I am gonna stop
it here when you were bitten and I'm
going to talking afterwards knowing her
I'm surprised you didn't shoot you she
almost did hope she's all right
I told you she's gonna be fine mmm I
wonder how many people in zombie
apocalypse get shot even though they're
immune like just to try to prevent it
okay so I'm gonna cut it here thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
not good great
like anything
only applies to this
and go down